mallorca eine insel abhängig vom
tourismus schwer getroffen von der
pandemie armut es gibt hier keine arbeit
die sommersaison darf nicht ins wasser
fallen
also wenn dieses jahr nicht funktioniert
werden wir werden wir das aufgeben
müssen hat sich die insel verkauft
wir brauchen einen anderen tourismus
tourismus fluch oder segen muss mallorca
sich neu erfinden
die südküste von mallorca hier segel
thema protons fast jeden tag auf neue
touristenmassen hat er keine lust
der mallorquiner und meeresforscher
arbeitet seit 25 jahren auf dem wasser
so klar wie jetzt hat es immer lange
nicht gesehen
es stimmt je weniger menschen desto
makelloser das meer
diese farbe die sie jetzt sehen sehen
sie im sommer nicht weniger schiffe
weniger fluglärm weniger touristen die
natur konnte sich seit dem letzten
lockdown erholen
sieben monate waren hier fast keine
touristen die balearen sind abhängig von
ihrer natur viel mehr als wir gedacht
haben
viele denken sie haben alles gute hotels
und tolle touristische einrichtungen
aber es ist die natur die unser größtes
gut unser größter schatz ist dieser
strand dieses mehr
dieser wind die sonne der umwelt auf
mallorca ging es schon lange nicht mehr
so gut doch die ruhe könnte bald vorbei
sein
[Musik]
denn jetzt kommen die deutschen wieder
mitmacht und frust aus dem kalten
shutdown
weil ich wieder nach berchtesgaden nach
sankt moritz nach oben
nach sankt peter ording nach sylt nach
neuharlingersiel noch werden in mode
oder zu meiner mutter nach hannover
können deshalb blickt man nach majak
deswegen fliegt man auch mal locker
haben sie auch hilde kommentare gehört
wie können sie jetzt war weg ja meine
arbeitskollegin die passanten gesagt ich
wäre ein kann die mini schwein und es
wäre moralisch verwerflich da habe ich
darauf geantwortet es gut und stehe dazu
vom flughafen fahren wir zum deutschen
touristen magneten den ballermann und
erleben wie der gerade aus dem
winterschlaf erwacht die cafés haben
geöffnet es gibt die ersten getränke in
der sonne einfach kommen und sich mal
kaffee zu trinken
draußen zu sitzen und weil hier die
inzidenz sehr gering sind einfach mal
raus von deutschland einfach mal keine
nachrichten und einfach mal ein bisschen
vergessen man hat jetzt war ein großes
gene konzept und masken und alles aber
das stört mich nicht das meer perfekt
doch immer noch haben nur zehn prozent
der hotels geöffnet
die tourismusbranche schreibt nachhilfe
viele menschen auf der insel warten
sehnsüchtig auf die urlauber
zehntausende sind im moment ohne job
können sich nicht mal das nötigste
leisten
es sind so viele dass zehn meisterin
zurzeit kaum noch hinterher kommen wir
treffen sie in cambridge einem anderen
stadtteil von palma sie kümmert sich
hier um die hungrigen und armen für ihre
hilfsorganisation sos mamma sammelt sie
lebensmittelspenden für die die sich
nicht mal mehr das essen leisten können
es sind viel mehr geworden 2009 10 haben
die mit 4000 personen angefangen heute
sind es zehn fast 11.000 verstehen sie
es hat sich wahnsinnig verändert die
zahl ist stark angestiegen
sie steigt immer noch und sie hört auch
nicht auf allzu standen um punkt 17 uhr
bildet sich wie jeden tag vor dem lager
eine schlange die meisten hier haben im
tourismus gearbeitet und ihre jobs
verloren
15 tage müssen die essensrationen
reichen für jeden der hier herkommt die
leute hier haben keine arbeit
sie verdienen nichts verstehen sie das
sind menschen die ganz unten sind
menschen wie jennifer villas kuss ohne
die tafel könnte sie sich und ihre
familie kombinieren
ihr sohn ist erst acht monate alt
deswegen kann sie ihre wohnung immer nur
kurz verlassen
hier wohnt die familie fünf menschen 240
quadratmeter vor allem gute und gesunde
lebensmittel für das baby kann sich die
familie kaum leisten
der kleiner ist gerade in der
wachstumsphase
er ist quasi jeden tag gemüse bis
oktober hatte jennifer einen befristeten
vertrag als zimmermädchen in einem hotel
doch der wurde wegen der krise nicht
verlängert weil sie nicht fest
angestellt war hat sie jetzt kein
anrecht auf kurzarbeitergeld die miete
für diese wohnung kann sie deswegen
schon länger nicht mehr bezahlen
jeder zeit hörte sie obdachlos werden
es ist schwer es ist sehr schwer nach
allem was mir passiert ist ich muss mich
damit auseinandersetzen
ich weiß nicht wie lange wir noch hier
bleiben können
vielleicht müssen wir morgen raus
vielleicht in einem monat ich weiß dass
der vermieter von dem lebt was wir
bezahlen aber wenn wir keinen job haben
können wir auch nicht bezahlen
ich meine so gerne wir würden wir können
ihn nicht bezahlen
jetzt kommen deutsche touristen was
erhoffen sie sich von ihnen sie sollen
keine angst haben
wir passen hier so sehr auf vor allem
weil wir eine insel sind die vom
tourismus lebt unsere insel braucht den
tourismus wenn die touristen nicht
kommen wird dass noch mehr leute treffen
als jetzt ohnehin schon für ihre kinder
hofft jennifer dass es wieder losgeht
mit dem tourismus dass sie wieder
arbeiten und so wenigstens ihre miete
bezahlen kann
[Musik]
eine autostunde von palma entfernt liegt
im südosten der insel das bei touristen
sehr beliebte cala d'or ihr sind sie
bereits zu öffnen
wir sind bei familie tannert seit zehn
jahren betreiben sie dieses kleine hotel
heute treffen sie die letzten
vorbereitungen die saison soll zu ostern
starten
[Musik]
im moment spielen wir noch nicht den
grossen die großen ansturm aber wir sind
guter hoffnung dass es kommt wir haben
soweit ist alles vorbereitet meint ich
gäste können die gäste jetzt ab heute zu
uns kommen
ein letzter rundgang durch die zimmer
fünf mitarbeiterinnen hat das hotel in
festanstellung doch eine saison wie
letztes jahr können sich die taz nicht
leisten
wir sind sehr froh dass er unsere
mitarbeiter in ehrte sind denn da
kurzarbeiter regelung dass wir den
finanziellen druck ein bisschen
rausnehmen können
aber was was leider in spanien komplett
fehlt ist die die hilfe für die
selbständigen die ist wenn man das zu
deutschland vergleicht 0
in cala d'or wohnen im winter 2000
menschen im sommer sind es 30.000 der
ort ist komplett auf touristen ausgelegt
jeder hier lebt von ihnen wenn die
großen reiseanbieter nicht kommen haben
sie in cala d'or ein problem was
passiert denn wenn diese saison auch
ausfällt ja das ist die große frage also
es gibt keinen danach also wenn dieses
jahr nicht funktioniert werden wir
würden wir es aufgeben müssen
dennis ende
wie geht es weiter nach corona die
pandemie stellt vieles ganz
grundsätzlich in frage
doch nicht nur die tourismus lobby
trommelt für ihre sache auch die
kritischen stimmen werden lauter wir
sind verabredet mit power audrey ist
erster bekannt ist der insel
karikaturist und kritisiert mit seinen
zeichnungen seit 25 jahren den
massentourismus seiner meinung nach hat
mallorca sich verkauft er macht das in
seinen wöchentlichen karikaturen
deutlich hier sehen wir dass einige
wenige leute mehr gewicht auf geld als
auf die gesundheit legen
ich finde sie schaden damit der
wirtschaft mehr weil sie nur eine
lächerliche touristensaison bekommt das
ist zu kurz gedacht
im gegenzug bricht für den rest des
jahres die wirtschaft ein
wegen des virus können dann nicht nur
touristen sondern auch die bewohner
nicht mehr in die geschäfte oder
restaurants gehen aus karikaturen sind
unbequem für viele deren lebensunterhalt
vom tourismus abhängt doch für paul ist
klar das virus bedroht seine insel und
für schnelles geld sollte man nicht die
gesundheit der menschen opfern
es ist nicht besonders intelligent jetzt
alles auf die sommersaison zu setzen
das könnte nach hinten losgehen auf
spanisch sagt man brot für heute aber
hunger für morgen bittet um die probleme
von heute an zu gehen sei gerade
nachhaltigkeit bitter nötig sagt uns
im norden der insel fit wird das was
paust traum von tourismus auf mallorca
ist auf 150 hektar steht eine renovierte
finca alles was sie für die versorgung
der gäste brauchen erzeugen sie selbst
francisco leitet das familienunternehmen
in dritter generation in den
olivenhainen zeigte uns seine
freilaufenden mallorquinischen schweine
[Musik]
wie viele sind es
ich glaube 65 15 mütter und 65 fertig
der strom aus sonnenenergie das abwasser
wieder aufbereitet das essen aus eigener
landwirtschaft seit 26 jahren machen sie
das hier schon so tourismus im einklang
mit der natur
[Musik]
ich glaube tourismus überall muss die
umwelt respektieren und auch mallorca
verändert sich dahingehend wir sind
nicht die einzigen es gibt hier viele
hotels auch am meer die sich um die
umwelt sorgen
kein massentourismus mehr nachhaltigkeit
francisco will dass dieses konzept
schule macht
zurück in der inselhauptstadt palma ihr
freut man sich dass das leben
zurückgekehrt ist cafés restaurants
alles ist bis 17 uhr offen endlich und
das genießen auch die deutschen
touristen
doch gefährden sie den bisherigen erfolg
der insel in der pandemie
die zahlen steigen jedenfalls wieder
leicht die mallorquiner die hier treffe
sind hin und hergerissen
wenn so viele leute kommen dann weiß ich
auch nicht
das ist eine wirtschaftliche
entscheidung keine gesundheitliche mir
gefällt es gut dass die deutschen können
aber die situation was unter kontrolle
und welche schlüsse zieht die politik
aus der krise wir fragen nach bei der
präsidentin des inselrats katharina klar
wäre okay sie sagen selbst dass mallorca
vom tourismus abhängig ist wäre jetzt
der moment sich neu zu erfinden
der tourismus ist allgegenwärtig
wir würden gerne daran glauben dass
jetzt der moment ist sich zu wandeln
es gibt den wunsch nach mehr
veränderungen dass wir uns nicht mehr
nur auf die sommermonate sonne und
strand konzentrieren
obwohl das natürlich unsere
verkaufsschlager sind wir wollen keines
auf tourismus und andere exzesse
wir würden gerne auf qualitätstourismus
setzen in einklang mit dem was die insel
ausmacht nämlich die schöne natur ein
wunsch der sich kurzfristig nicht
erfüllen wird zu groß der druck aus der
tourismusindustrie zu hoch die
arbeitslosigkeit mallorca ist noch nicht
so weit aber das umdenken hat begonnen
mitten in der pandemie